Speaker 1: Solar power is suddenly awesome
on Fox News now that these Chinese balloons
are being asserted without evidence to have
extraordinarily advanced solar power capabilities.
This is so far these Fox News people are so
predictable and and it's so funny in a way,
if it weren't so sad.
Once again, Fox News propagandist Maria BARTIROMO
is starting to talk about solar panels and
in the context of the Chinese balloons she
again brought up.
This is now the second weekend in a row that
Maria brings up.
They are getting unlimited power from these
solar panels.
They have unlimited energy.
Wow.
If if now solar panels represent not some
woke distraction from burning fossil fuels,
but rather unlimited energy.
Seems like we should be taking soeder more
seriously in the U.S., don't you think?
Here's Maria BARTIROMO yesterday.
Speaker 5: Is the CCP up to is this a test?
And by the way, I've learned over the weekend
that these balloons, the largest one, that,
you know, you could fit three busses in it
that was shot down over South Carolina last
Saturday.
That balloon was able to snap images of our
military installations and send them back
to China in live time.
So what John Ratcliffe told us last week was
spot on.
They were using solar panels for unlimited
power, unlimited energy to continue the surveillance
program.
Speaker 1: Damn, those solar panels, they're
getting the best of us because they're so
awesome.
Unlimited power.
It's crazy.
What about clouds?
Like Trump said?
What about night time?
All of a sudden, solar power, the holy grail
of surveillance and spying.
And remember, last weekend she proposed something
similar.
Speaker 5: China didn't drop.
And just for surveillance products powered
by solar energy to allow unlimited surveillance.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Without any evidence whatsoever.
Maria suggesting, you know, when they popped
the balloon, when Biden popped the balloon,
it might have released micro surveillance
elements powered by the sun, which could in
perpetuity surveil the United States.
Wow.
It's amazing.
Such technology even exists with solar power.
Maria So solar power sounds pretty damn awesome.
Now if you watch Maria BARTIROMO program.
According to Fox News, it sounds like solar
energy is really the way to go.
So of course we're sort of being tongue in
cheek here, sort of being facetious.
It would be great.
Great for them to just take solar panels and
solar power.
10% as seriously as they are taking it now
in general, rather than doing their normal
stuff.
It's not sunny enough in the United States
for solar power.
That would never work.
Oh, but what about when it's cloudy out there?
We just don't know.
Just take it 10% as seriously as you're taking
it now.
And we would all be way better off